well it has been
681 days since the world health
organization declared kobit 19 a
pandemic it's been a rough couple of
years and sometimes it feels like it's
never going to end but medical experts
say there's a chance things could change
for the better in 2022 sasha loftis
talks to an optimistic health expert and
she joins us now live with more tonight
sasha
denise the expert i spoke with tonight
says the kovit 19 virus will never
really go away but it will become more
manageable and he believes that could
happen sooner than we think
it's been nearly two years since our
world was turned upside down by the
kovit 19 pandemic it's still unfortunate
after a serious spike in these past few
weeks clark county reported a drop in
daily cases while our positivity rate
held steady both thursday and friday i
think there's reason to expect a light
at the end of the tunnel unlv medical
school dean dr mark j khan says we're
not out of the woods but he's seeing
positive signs over time
the virus becomes much more
transmissible
and much less likely to cause death he
told us omicron which is now nevada's
dominant variant is more mild for most
who are vaccinated and follows that
trend we're going to develop a herd
immunity from both vaccination and from
natural infection he explained that over
time viruses like covet become endemic
meaning they're much less lethal like
the flu or common cold when we look
historically at pandemics in the human
population they last about two years the
viral pandemics we're about that point
now the consensus khan and other experts
believe things could soon change for the
better it's eventually going to happen
that way giving us a glimpse of the
normalcy we've all wanted for so long it
will get better
now of course there is no set timeline
for any of this and of course experts
say this does depend on future covet 19
variants hospitalization rates are still
high in southern nevada so dr khan still
recommends getting vaccinated getting
your booster and wearing a mask
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now